>>> YOU'RE LIVE IN THE CNN
"NEWSROOM."
I'M JIM ACOSTA IN WASHINGTON.
WE'RE GETTING A NEW WINDOW INTO
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S TRYING
TO EXPLAIN WYOMING HE HOSTED A
DINNER AT MAR-A-LAGO WITH WHITE
NATIONALISTS AND HOLOCAUST
DENIER NICK FUENTES AND RAPPER
KANYE WEST, WHO HAS BEEN IN THE
HEADLINES FOR ANTI-SEMITIC
REMARKS.
HE SAID KANYE WEST CALLED ME TO
HAVE DINNER AT TKAURL.
SHORTLY HE UNEXPECTEDLY SHOWED
UP WITH THREE OF HIS FRIENDS
WHOM I KNEW NOTHING ABOUT.
AGAIN, THIS IS HIS STATEMENT.
THE DINNER WAS QUICK AND
UNEVENTFUL.
THEN THEY LEFT FOR THE AIRPORT.
JOINING ME NOW IS FORMER
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN CHARLIE
DENT AND FORMER CLINTON WHITE
HOUSE AIDE KEITH WOEUKIN.
CHARLIE, LET ME START WITH YOU
FIRST.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO HOW --
IT SOUNDS AS THOUGH HE IS TRYING
TO MAKE THIS GO AWAY.
IT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE IT IS
GOING TO GO AWAY.
>>> NO, JIM.
THIS IS SKPHRAOE INEXCUSABLE
THAT HE WOULD HAVE DINNER WITH
THIS ANTI-ESSENTIAL MIGHT NICK
FUENTES AND KANYE WEST AND ALL
OF HIS BAGGAGE.
IT IS PAULING THAT THIS
HAPPENED.
IT IS INCUMBENT UPON THE
REPUBLICAN ESTABLISHMENT, WHAT'S
LEFT OF IT, TO STAMP THIS OUT
ONCE AND FOR ALL.
WE SAW IT FOR WILLIAM F. BUCKLEY
AND THE THEY GOT RID OF THE
EFFORT.
THE UGLY HISTORICAL
CONNOTATIONINGS BACK IN THE
1930s HAS BEEN FORGOTTEN BY TOO
MANY OF OUR FELLOW CITIZENS,
REGRETTABLY.
BUT IT ALSO SPEAKS TO A LARGER
PROBLEM.
THERE APPARENTLY ARE NO
GATEKEEPERS, NO DAUNTS.
THERE DOESN'T SEEM TO BE ANY
POLITICAL DISCIPLINE HOW A
DINNER LIKE THIS COULD EVEN
HAPPEN IS ALSO HORRIBLE.
BUT FINALLY I GUESS I WOULD SAY
THIS FURTHER DIMINISHING DONALD
TRUMP AS A SERIOUS POLITICAL
FIGURE.
ELSE MISS OWE POINTS SHOULD BE
QUITE HAPPY ABOUT THIS BECAUSE
IT WILL ELEVATE THEM AND HURT
TRUMP.
BUT HE IS STILL A DANGEROUS
FIGURE.
THE PARTY NEEDS TO DEAL WITH THE
LARGER ISSUE.
WE CAN'T A LEE NATE AND OFF THE
SIZING KIN ZINGER AND LIZ
CHENEY.
>> KEITH, THIS REALLY MAGNIFIES
WHY TRUMP IS A GLOBAL
EMBARRASSMENT.
THIS ISN'T THE FIRST TIME TRUMP
HAS CLAIMED I DIDN'T KNOW WHO
THAT WAS.
HE FAMOUSLY SAID THAT SAME THING
BACK IN 2016 WHEN HE WAS ASKED
ABOUT DAVID DUKE, THE FORMER KKK
GRAND WIZARD SUPPORTING THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN AT THAT TIME.
LET'S TAKE A LISTEN TO THAT.
>> JUST SO YOU UNDERSTAND, I
DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT DAVID
DUKE.
I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT WHAT
YOU'RE EVEN TALKING ABOUT WITH
WHITE SUPREMACY OR WHITE
SUPREMACISTS.
I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW DID HE ENDORSE ME
OR WHAT'S GOING ON?
I KNOW NOTHING ABOUT DAVID DUKE.
I KNOW NOTHING ABOUT WHITE
SUPREMACISTS.
>> THEN OF COURSE THERE WAS WHAT
HE SAID AFTER CHARLOTTESVILLE.
I WAS ACTUALLY THERE AND HEARD
IT.
THIS IS WHAT HE SAID.
>> YOU ALSO HAD PEOPLE THAT WERE
VERY FINE PEOPLE, ON BOTH SIDES.
EXCUSE ME, EXCUSE ME.
I SAW THE SAME PICTURES AS YOU
DID.
>> AND WE ALL REMEMBER TRUMP
TELLING THE PROUD BOYS TO STAND
BACK AND STAND BY DURING A
PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE.
WHY IS IT SO HARD FOR HIM TO
DISAVOW THESE PEOPLE?
>> HE DOESN'T WANT TO DISAVOW
THESE PEOPLE, JIM.
THIS IS PART OF HIS BRAND.
THIS IS HOW HE STARTED HIS
CAREER IN POLITICS.
REMEMBER, HE SPENT FIVE AND A
HALF YEARS LYING ABOUT THE FIRST
BLACK PRESIDENT'S BIRTH
CERTIFICATE.
HE ATTACKED MEXICANS SAYING THEY
WERE RAIN I HAVE THES AND DRUG
DEALERS.
AND HE WAS GOING TO HAVE A TOTAL
AND COMPLETE BAN OF ALL MUSLIMS
INTO THE COUNTRY.
SO HE HAS HAD A HISTORY OF
DEALING WITH ANTI-SEMITISM,
BIGOTRY TO GET SUPPORT FOR HIS
POLITICAL AMBITIONS.
I DISAGREE WITH CHARLIE, THOUGH.
I UNDERSTAND WHY HE WOULD WANT
TO SAY THIS AS A REPUBLICAN.
BUT CHARLIE IS SUGGESTING THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS GOING TO BE HURT
BY THIS.
I'M NOT CONVINCED THAT HE WILL.
WE HAVE THE SAME SCANDALS OR
SCANDALS LIKE THIS WHEN TRUMP
RAN FOR PRESIDENT IN 2016.
IT DIDN'T STOP HIM.
HE BECAME MORE POPULAR.
AND THAT WING OF THE PARTY
BECAME MORE EMBOLDENED BECAUSE
OF HIM.
IN A TRADITIONAL WORLD THERE
WOULD BE ENORMOUS REPERCUSSIONS
ASSOCIATING WITH NICK FUENTES, A
WHITE SUPREMACIST AND CLAIMING
HE DIDN'T KNOW IT.
BUT IN THE REAL WORLD WE ARE
LIVING IN TODAY, I DON'T THINK
IT WILL HURT DONALD TRUMP.
I THINK IT WILL HELP DONALD
TRUMP IN SOME QUARTERS.
>> WHEN ARE REPUBLICAN LEADERS
GOING ON SPEAK OUT ABOUT THIS?
>> WELL, LOOK, I THINK A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS ARE SIMPLY SICK AND
TIRED OF LOSING.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
THIS IS NOT NEW FOR DONALD
TRUMP, HIS EMBRACE OF THESE
SKETCHY BIGOTED FIGURES, GOING
BACK TO THE MUSLIMS, THE MEXICAN
COMMENTS AND OF COURSE
CHARLOTTESVILLE.
SOME REPUBLICANS ARE SPEAKING UP
AND SPEAKING UP MORE FORCEFULLY.
WHAT BROUGHT THEM TO THE TABLE
BELATEDLY ADMITTEDLY, THEY HAVE
SEEN DEFEAT.
NOTHING GETS MORE PEOPLE
MOTIVATED TO CHANGE COURSE THAN
DEFEAT.
NOW,IVE WISH PEOPLE BECAME MORE
OFFENDED BY THESE INCENDIARY
COMMENTS TRUMP HAS MADE OVER THE
YEARS.
BUT UNTIL ENOUGH OF THE ELECTED
LEADERS OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
AND THE REPUBLICAN ESTABLISHMENT
STAND UP AND FORCEFULLY CONDEMN
THIS, THAT IS WHAT WILL CHANGE
THE NARRATIVE.
IF IT'S TOO FEW PEOPLE, WE'RE
NOT GOING TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
WE NEED STRONG LEADERSHIP.
SILENCE IS NOT A WAY TO COUNTER
THAT UGLY TRUMP NARRATIVE.
YOU HAVE TO COUNTER IT WITH A
VOICE AND A STRONG COLLECTIVE
VOICE.
AND I BELIEVE THERE ARE ENOUGH
PEOPLE OUT THERE.
SLOWLY IT'S COMING AROUND.
BUT WE'RE NOT THERE YET.
>> KEITH --
>> I THINK THAT'S A --
>> GO AHEAD.
>> I THINK THAT'S A BIT OF
WISHFUL THINKING, CHARLIE.
I JOIN YOU IN HOPING THERE WOULD
BE SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
IT'S SATURDAY.
WHERE ARE THE REPUBLICAN
LEADERS.
WHAT DID KEVIN McCARTHY SAY,
MITCH McCONNELL SAY?
HAVE THEY BEEN ASKED ABOUT IT,
STATED AN OPINION ON IT?
NOBODY IS COMMENTING BECAUSE
THIS IS WHO DONALD TRUMP IS, THE
FORMER REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT.
THEY KNOW THAT IS WHAT HE IS.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT NO
GATEKEEPERS ARE PREVENTING THIS
TYPE OF MEETING FROM HAPPENING.
I UNDERSTAND THAT TOO.
BUT THAT IS ALSO PART OF DONALD
TRUMP'S BRAND.
THERE WERE NO GATEKEEPERS WHEN
HE WAS IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
THAT IS THE REASON WE HAD THE
INSURRECTION.
WE SAW THAT FROM THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE HEARINGS.
HE HAS CONSISTENTLY LIVED IN THE
WORLD FROM HIS BUSINESS
EXPERIENCE TO WHERE HE HAS NEVER
HAD ANYONE TELL HIM NO.
I'M NOT CONVINCED A GATE KEEPER
WOULD MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
THIS IS WHO DONALD TRUMP IS.
THIS IS WHO THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
CHOSE TO BE THEIR NOMINEE FOR
PRESIDENT IN TWO CONSECUTIVE
ELECTIONS.
THIS IS NOW THE LEADER OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, DONALD TRUMP.
>> YOU WERE GOING TO RESPOND TO
THAT?
>> IT IS FOR MITCH McCONNELL,
FOR WHOM I HAVE MUCH RESPECT
FOR.
AND WHERE HE MADE COMMENTS ABOUT
HIS WIFE, ANTI-ASIAN.
THEY NEED TO SPEAK UP.
SILENCE IS NOT AN ANSWER.
IF NOT NOW, WHEN?
HE IS REELING BECAUSE OF THE
MIDTERM ELECTION AND SOME OF THE
OTHER RECENT EVENTS.
NOW IS THE TIME TO PUT THEM
DOWN.
AND YOU CAN'T LET THEM OFF THE
MAT LIKE THEY DID AFTER JANUARY
THE 6th.